le tournage du film les grandes gueules
est pratiquement terminée en termes de
métiers ont dit que le film est en boîte
michel ardan pour vous qu est le
producteur de ce film qu'est ce que ça
représente
je crois que pour tous les producteurs
ça représente à peu près la même chose
la fin d'un film
on est content on est content surtout
que ça soit fini mais je dois dire pour
ce que pour le film les grandes gueules
c'est vraiment c'est une joie de l'avoir
terminé parce que moralement pour moi ça
a été terrible mais par rapport à aux
autres films que vous avez produit à bas
c'est à dire que les autres films enfin
tous les prix et les trois films que
j'ai produit ils sont en général des
films d'action mais celui là était
particulièrement d'action vraiment on a
eu des coups durs sur coup dur enfin
c'était plus vivable vous comprenez ne
parlons pas dans toute la france le
temps qui fait bon ça on s'en est sorti
la question n'est pas là mais je parle
de tous les accidents tous les jours on
a risqué
je pars pas dans les bagarres par
exemple car ce qu'un film d'action
terrible plusieurs fois j'étais même pas
content que je dois dire la vérité je me
disais non enrico pourquoi ils bougent
pourquoi il va si loin
on peut peut-être faire autrement et
dans le fond aujourd'hui on est tous
contents quand est-ce que je me serais
vous avez pris des risques mais il a
pris des risques terribles et moi j'ai
pris des risques aussi puisque le tout
est marqué dans le scénario avant je
n'avais qu'à pas l'accepter alors c'est
un film plein d'action vous comprenez
résultat on a toutes les bagarres de
paniers me savais où on a tourné la fête
foraine à je dois remercier été tourné à
vanier oui et je dois remercier vraiment
la ville de vanier qui nous a donné un
coup de main formidable je sais pas si
vous avez vu la fête foraine pour nous
ça a été un travail très très dur
les bagarres bas ma foi lino ventura a
été dans le plâtre j'ai eu et ça va
compliquer dans ce film j'ai eu cinq
pieds cassés et à commencer par
l'opérateur qui le troisième jour ces
tracés le pied aussi dans les dents dans
le mouvement parce que tout le monde y
met du sien
il a continué à tourner avec le plate
mais ça je dois dire une chose
formidable
enfin pas pu partir pour l'instant dit
par exemple alors qu'on a mis tout ce
qu'il fallait pour pour faire flamber la
cabane cette scène finale où on voit le
fehr qui flambent bah oui et tout d'un
coup quitte à flamber plus fort qu'on la
pensait on cherche l opérateur partout
il était resté dans la cabane vous
comprenez
pour le réalisateur pour le producteur
pour toute l'équipe du film
il se termine ni enfin il se termine
bien mais pour bourges et les pros lino
ventura c'est pas la même chose
c'était prévu a marqué a pas de surprise
c'est prévu que le haut faire brûler
avec eux une bataille à lacanau et que
j'irai dans l'eau alors vous avez vous
avez pris le bain fatalement dont on
fait les choses aussi résignée et vous
bah moi pareil cambrai un mois j'ai
grillé puis bien trempé quoi vous en
sortez pas trop mal quand même
malheureusement c'est pas facile ça
c'est un peu le cochon brûlé mais enfin
c est ce que vous avez un souvenir
particulier de ce film bah oui je crois
que ça fait là aujourd'hui même je crois
que ça fait là sixième cheville foulée
ou cassés en comptant la vôtre comptant
la mienne dans la bagarre à vanier oui
c'est une épidémie du chum que ces chefs
opérateurs bostik a commencé avec un
pied cassé et aujourd'hui c'est
l'habilleuse à bourvil ça fait la
sixième
quant à moi je passe rien
si d'un maupassant et ce séjour dans les
vosges
bah oui c'est un peu mouillé un peu
mouillé mais alors il paraît que c'est
général parce que les gens nous disent
si vous étiez nuée dernière je sais pas
si c'est pas si les téléspectateurs ne
vont pas s'en rendre compte mais
pourtant vous avez l'air très bronzé et
ça c'est sa coquetterie qui lui fait
dire cela je suis je suis pas trop près
comme de liquides non cahiers du soleil
évidemment c'est merveilleux c'est un
merveilleux pays
oui d'accord ce faut le dire
malheureusement je crois qu'on n'a pas
été gâté mal temps mais si vous étiez
nuit hier